welcome to this video on playing savio
lhasa from Brazil completing before and
I'm going from with this english defence
and I III system between strained way to
play not a bad one just a bit
conservative interesting young ok let's
play it like that listen that's their DS
to play with 'if I've like II for takes
takes me five now that's enterprising
okay I'll play in the center
yeah of course one problem is that this
bishop on b7 is not particularly well
placed but wyd some position is also not
ideal okay bit afraid of tea sixths this
kind of stuff okay 97 to c5 is this good
not clear
yeah probably probably I should do that
but it's not clear to me at all this
position I have not cashed out yet they
don't intend to son can easily be a
problem check what who is what I'm just
playing this and when a piece or not
Queen B 5 as a strange move just Quincy
do and this it even loses the Queen here
Queen to before runs into light XD three
winning everything
Jim queen bee five check is a white
there's a really a big big lemon yeah
you should go to to see two of course
and this is just very complicated stuff
tattoo how to evaluate I thought Queen
g7 maybe always giving me the chance to
to take him gaining the bishops and it
also introduces long castling which
might be preferable here because h4 h5
quickly will open up the edge file I
don't want to cancel shorty em hard to
save very a very complicated position
this some has a bit surprising edge
floor I thought I was thinking oops not
this one thinking more about form after
which my idea was to play like that it
leads to quite quite interesting
positions yeah but we didn't we didn't
get there he played the screen b5 stuff
alright thanks for watching